now another blm leader is being sued for  stealing allegedly 10 million dollars  this is a top leader in the black lives  matter global network foundation accused  in a lawsuit of  stealing 10 million through a scheme of  fraud and misrepresentation this  lawsuit was filed by another blm group  blm grassroots it accused shalomia  bowers one of the national group's three  members on the board of directors of  stealing the 10 million bucks for  personal use okay what you have in this  lawsuit is not one group seeking justice  and another just one bad apple you know  kind of spoiling the whole group no you  just have  two  rich political operations fighting over  money